[Music]
in a previous video I've talked about
linear systems of equations and I sort
of brushed aside the discussion of
actually computing solutions to these
systems and while it's true that the
number crunching is typically something
we leave to the computers digging into
some of these computational methods is a
good litmus test for whether or not you
actually understand what's going on
since that's really where the rubber
meets the road here I want to describe
the geometry behind a certain method for
computing solutions to these systems
known as Kramer's rule the relevant
background here is understanding
determinants a little bit of dot
products and of course linear systems of
equations so be sure to watch the
relevant videos on those topics if
you're unfamiliar or rusty but first I
should say up front that this Kramer's
rule is not actually the best way for
computing solutions to linear systems of
equations Gaussian elimination for
example will always be faster so why
learn it well think of it as a sort of
cultural excursion it's a helpful
exercise in deepening your knowledge of
the theory behind these systems wrapping
your mind around this concept is going
to help consolidate ideas from linear
algebra like the determinants and linear
systems by seeing how they relate to
each other also from a purely artistic
standpoint the ultimate result here is
just really pretty to think about way
more so than Gaussian elimination
alright so the setup here will be some
linear system of equations say with two
unknowns x and y and two equations in
principle everything we're talking about
will also work for systems with larger
number of unknowns and the same number
of equations but for simplicity a
smaller example is just nicer to hold in
our heads so as I talked about in a
previous video you can think of this set
up geometrically as a certain known
matrix transforming an unknown vector X
Y where you know what the output is
going to be in this case negative 4
negative 2
remember the columns of this matrix are
telling you how that matrix acts as a
transform each one telling you where the
basis vectors of the input space land so
what we have is a sort of puzzle which
input vector XY is going to land on this
output negative 4 negative 2 one way to
think about our little puzzle here is
that we know the given output vector is
some linear combination of the columns
of the matrix x times the vector where I
hat lands plus y times the vector where
J hat lands but what we want is to
figure out what exactly that linear
combination should be remember the type
of answer you get here can depend on
whether or not the transformation
squishes all of space into a lower
dimension that is if it has a 0
determinant in that case either none of
the inputs land on our given output or
there's a whole bunch of inputs landing
on that output
but for this video will limit our view
to the case of a nonzero determinant
meaning the outputs of this
transformation still span the full in
dimensional space that it started in
every input lands on one and only one
output and every output has one and only
one input
as a first pass let me show you an idea
that's wrong but in the right direction
the x-coordinate of this mystery input
vector is what you get by taking its dot
product with the first basis vector 1 0
likewise the y-coordinate is what you
get by dotting it with the second basis
vector 0 1 so maybe you hope that after
the transformation the dot products with
the transformed version of the mystery
vector with the transformed version of
the basis vectors will also be these
coordinates x and y that would be
fantastic
because we know what the transformed
version of each of those vectors are
there's just one problem with it it's
not at all true for most linear
transformations the dot product before
and after the transformation will look
very different for example you could
have two vectors generally pointing in
the same direction with a positive dot
product which get pulled apart from each
other during the transformation in such
a way that they end up having a negative
dot product
likewise things that start off
perpendicular with dot product zero like
the two basis vectors quite often don't
stay perpendicular to each other after
the transformation that is they don't
preserve that zero dot product and
looking at the example I just showed dot
products certainly aren't preserved they
tend to get bigger
since most vectors are getting stretched
out in fact worthwhile side note here
transformations which do preserve dot
products are special enough to have
their own name or the normal
transformations these are the ones that
leave all of the basis vectors
perpendicular to each other and still
with unit lengths you often think of
these as the rotation matrices they
correspond to rigid motion with no
stretching or squishing or morphing
solving a linear system with an
orthonormal matrix is actually super
easy because dot products are preserved
taking the dot product between the
output vector and all the columns of
your matrix will be the same as taking
the dot product between the mystery
input vector and all of the basis
vectors which is the same as just
finding the coordinates of that mystery
input so in that very special case X
would be the dot product of the first
column with the output vector and Y
would be the dot product of the second
column with the output vector
why am i bringing this up when this idea
breaks down for almost all linear
systems well it points us in a direction
of something to look for is there an
alternate geometric understanding for
the coordinates of our input vector that
remains unchanged after the
transformation if your mind has been
mulling over determinants you might
think of the following clever idea
take the parallelogram defined by the
first basis vector I hat and the mystery
input vector XY the area of this
parallelogram is the base one times the
height perpendicular to that base which
is the y coordinate of that input vector
so the area of that parallelogram is a
sort of screwy roundabout way to
describe the vectors y coordinate it's a
wacky way to talk about coordinates but
run with me and actually to be a little
more accurate you should think of this
as the signed area of that parallelogram
in the sense described in the
determinant video that way a vector with
a negative y coordinate would correspond
to a negative area for this
parallelogram at least if you think of I
hat as in some sense being the first out
of these two vectors defining the
parallelogram and symmetrically if you
look at the parallelogram spanned by our
mystery input vector and the second
basis J hat it's area is going to be the
x coordinate of that mystery vector
again it's a strange way to represent
the x coordinate but you'll see what it
buys us in a moment and just to make
sure it's clear how this might
generalize let's look in three
dimensions ordinarily the way you might
think about one of a vectors coordinates
say it's Z coordinate would be to take
its dot product with the third standard
basis vector often called K hat but an
alternate geometric interpretation would
be to consider the parallelepiped that
it creates with the other two basis
vectors I hat and J hat if you think of
these square with area one spanned by I
hat and J hat is the base of this whole
shape then its volume is the same as its
height which is the third coordinate of
our vector
and likewise the wacky way to think
about the other coordinates of the
vector would be to form a parallelepiped
using the vector and then all of the
basis vectors other than the one
corresponding to the direction you're
looking for then the volume of this
gives you the coordinate or rather we
should be talking about the signed
volume of parallelepipeds in the sense
described in the determinants video
using the right hand rule so the order
in which you list these three vectors
matters that way negative coordinates
still make sense okay so why think of
coordinates as areas and volumes like
this well as you apply some sort of
matrix transformation the areas of these
parallelograms
well they don't stay the same they might
get scaled up or down but and this is
the key idea of determinants all of the
areas get scaled by the same amount
namely the determinant of our
transformation matrix for example if you
look at the parallelogram spanned by the
vector where your first basis vector
lands which is the first column of the
matrix and the transformed version of X
Y what is its area well this is the
transformed version of the parallelogram
we were looking at earlier the one whose
area was the y coordinate of the mystery
input vector so it's area is just going
to be the determinant of the
transformation multiplied by that
y-coordinate so that means we can solve
for y by taking the area of this new
parallelogram in the output space
divided by the determinant of the full
transformation
how do you get that area well we know
the coordinates for where the mystery
input vector lands that's the whole
point of a linear system of equations so
what you might do is create a new matrix
whose first column is the same as that
of our matrix but whose second column is
the output vector and then you take its
determinant so look at that just using
data from the output of the
transformation namely the columns of the
matrix and the coordinates of our output
vector we can recover the y coordinate
of the mystery input vector which is
halfway to solving the system likewise
the same idea can give us the x
coordinate look at the parallelogram we
defined earlier which encodes the x
coordinate of the mystery input vector
spanned by that vector and j-hat the
transformed version of this guy is
spanned by the output vector and the
second column of the matrix and its area
will have been multiplied by the
determinant of that matrix so to solve
for x you can take this new area divided
by the determinant of the full
transformation and similar to what we
did before you can compute the area of
that output parallelogram by creating a
new matrix whose first column is the
output vector and whose second column is
the same as the original matrix so again
just using data from the output space
the numbers we see in our original
linear system we can solve for what X
must be this formula for finding the
solutions to a linear system of
equations is known as Kramer's rule here
just a sanity check ourselves plug in
some numbers here the determinant of
that top altered matrix is 4 plus 2
which is 6 and the bottom determinant is
2 so the x-coordinate should be 3 and
indeed looking back at the input vector
we started with the x-coordinate is 3
likewise Kramer's rule suggests that the
y-coordinate should be 4 divided by 2 or
2 and that is in fact the y-coordinate
of the input vector that we were
starting with the case with 3 dimensions
or more is similar and I highly
recommend that you take a moment to
pause and think through it yourself here
I'll give you a little bit of momentum
what we have is a known transformation
given by some 3x3 matrix and a known
output vector given by the right side of
our linear system
and we want to know what input lands on
that output and if you think of say the
Z coordinate of that input vector as the
volume of that special parallelepiped we
were looking at earlier spanned by I hat
J hat and the mystery input vector what
happens to that volume after the
transformation and what are the various
ways that you can compute that volume
really pause and take a moment to think
through the details of generalizing this
to higher dimensions finding an
expression for each coordinate of the
solution to a larger linear system
thinking through more general cases like
this and convincing yourself that it
works and why it works is where all of
the learning really happens much more so
than listening to some dude on YouTube
walk you through the same reasoning
again
you
[Music]
you
[Music]